[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
jonah lomu de folie soit expire à l'ess
mois sur un succès sur ce qu'adam comme
c'est que si je perds pas au bord des
mêmes conclusions
donc c'est pas bon annoncé d'abord un
mauvais perdant vraiment vous pouvez
perdre nos musées pour lui dire il ne
s'est pas tu succès
[Applaudissements]
si vous perdez je vous jure que c'est
vrai ah ah bah je me fout à poil moins
et je fonde totalement je fais le tour
de françois berléand
[Applaudissements]
par contre si vous perdez c'est la honte
pour vous donc les neuf règles parce que
c'est moi aussi j'etais aus portent leur
avait juré que vous ne faites pas exprès
non je fais pas ça ne sera jamais le
chanteur pop de mende où j'ai jamais eu
mais pas le faire
offerts
on saura si c'est fait exprès et 6 kg de
points attention vous les prenez à bout
de bras comme si c'est juste une
question car si jamais j'ai des 500
signatures va dire que je vais faire les
émissions de pujadas des débats vont le
jouer à fond
pas plus calmes a perdu 1,1 attention
les rappeurs à ce jeu et vous savez ce
que j'ai pu j'ai eu un petit message de
booba a way
vous entendez bien que booba bon eh bien
il va peut-être passer aussi et tout à
l'heure à léonie tous fermés
[Applaudissements]
on y va et 89 à l'ego car il fait pas
commencé après c'est cet honneur aussi
d'honneur aussi un casque ou mathieu 1
j'ai toujours été fan de ducalcon à
thieu lam et chez un peu cramé à
vaujours du mur il ya 25 ans mais on
s'en fout de ce que ça va coûter pas
moins longtemps hanouna poil autour de
berne est en forme et clarika c'est
aussi car ils vivent est là risque c'est
que j'étais toujours aimé les projets
qu'on est quelqu'un que j'adore ça fait
combien de semaines que je veux tu
viennes dans l'émission ça fait combien
de fois que je dis de venir
tu peux pas me faire ça car ici c'est
karine en mai sur une plaque à risque
carrément cotchery alors sans égal et
non pas ce que tu veux que la chute des
fonds ce cas là je te défonce il a dit
ça a déjà ça sert à rien que pour ça
doit vous lire un passage aurait
d'autres raisons comme au foot à pois et
mac était pas de mathieu mathieu et
amadou bourou l'armée mais là j'ai fait
ce sport
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
là dessus